now that the show exists and obviously
there was a big time period between when
you are writing and now this whole other
world of people well it doesn't
influence the writing I'm doing now
except to turn off the stress because
the show first has caught up to me which
I didn't actually think would ever
happen I had something to lead
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm a very slow writer and David man are
and their staff are faster than I am and
I'm writing 1,500 page manuscripts and
they're running 60 page teller players
and you know the production machinery is
a locomotive that can't stop so you know
I've been hearing it come up behind me
for years and the question is well how
can I make myself write faster well I
think right now the answer is right then
and there we are
but what the show is doing is not going
to change what the book is doing I you
know I started writing about these
characters in this world in 1991 we
didn't even have the first meetings to
create a show until like 2008 so I got
like a 17 year it started Syrian period
period in my mind the rest of the world
you may look like Peter Dinklage but as
brilliant as Peter is he is brilliant
material in my head is still not
necessarily him as it
he's shorter and missing notice what we
couldn't do we did think of doing that
he was reluctant to actually let us
amputated
so if we did with CGI you would have to
hear we're a little green smooth for all
of the scenes but we would have to do it
digitally and that that we've been very
credible you've all said that one of the
week and of joy when you sat down to
write and you know initially you gave us
thrown into the rest of a song and ice
and fire after so many years what your
lighting is too expensive most expensiv
[Music]
consideration this would be almost
enjoyed if once again I don't let you
know I put the shorter side I don't do
that I have forgot the reverse I never
brought it back and say oh this is gonna
be too much for the show they will be
able to afford it not do it I do it
anyway and there's David Mann and
they're people to figure it out
and sometimes they can and sometimes
they can't you know in the first season
in particular we lost a lot of the
battles for example if we simply did
none of the budget the state battles but
if the show had gotten more popular but
this is Mike increase now we can do
sequences like heart and Blackwater
pretty cool battles I mean Blackwater
which I actually worked for adapting my
own stories is one of the best battles
we're not a wheelie on and I think you
have to say it probably at least one of
the 10 best battles ever done on
television but as great as it is in the
TV show its it's not a third of what's
on the book I mean in the book there's
all those developments there's you know
there's an entire army that's on the
other thing that's trying to come across
it posters you know the the burning
ships kind of locked together they crash
into each other and they form a bridge
of boats that people were swarming
across that at five gigantic Trebbia
phase that are throwing throwing
traitors of course the river
bodies are fully at the sky if I'm gonna
chain that goes across the harbor
there's a fire you know lots of lots of
elements that we simply cream important
to do but what they could afford that it
was pretty cool